The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
TADGE DRYJA: Last class, I
talked about payment channels
and lightning network.
So today we'll talk a bit
more about payment channels.
We'll recap a little
bit, and we'll
talk about some optimizations,
one of which is key addition,
the other is hash trees.
And then we'll talk
about cross-chain swaps
or cross-chain atomic swaps.
OK, so last time, the sort
of main idea of these payment
channels is you've got
this commitment transaction
and each party holds a sort
of different transaction
that has the same amounts but
slightly different scripts.
So it's spending from a
shared funding transaction.
And it's sending out to--
the one that's held by
Alice on her hard drive
sends to Bob in the clear.
Bob just gets his eight coins
with no ifs, ands, or buts.
However, when Alice
broadcasts this,
she needs to wait 100 blocks.
She needs to wait a day.
And if she reveals
this key to Bob,
now Bob can use Bob's key
in this revocable key,
and Bob can get these
coins immediately.
And the opposite is for Bob.
So when Bob has his transaction,
it's got Alice's signature.
He doesn't store his
own, because he can just
compute it quickly.
The two coins that go to
Alice go to her in the clear.
However, the eight coins
that Bob gets for himself,
he has to wait 100 blocks.
And during the 100
blocks, Alice can
sign if she has
Bob's revocation key.
OK, so that's the basic
idea of these outputs.
And then you construct these.
So when I say, Alice, one
bitcoin, Bob, nine bitcoin,
it's of the format in these.
The person who holds
that transaction
has a transaction where the
other party gets the coins
immediately, and their own
coins have this lockup period,
and can be grabbed by the other
party if they revoke them.
So initially, the state is Alice
has one bitcoin, Bob has nine.
There's two different
state 1 transactions, one
held by Alice, one held by Bob.
They build a new
transaction together
where Alice has five coins
and Bob has five coins,
and then they revoke the old
one by sharing these secrets.
So now, since they both
have handed each other these
revocation private keys, both of
these parties cannot broadcast
this.
If they do, the other
party takes all the money.
And then you can build
these indefinitely.
OK, so any questions about that?
That was covered last time, but
it kind of can be complicated.
Questions?
Good?
OK, so some optimizations
we'd want to make--
yes, so basically, either party
broadcasts and has to wait.
Alice gives Bob the
AliceR private key,
Bob gives Alice the
BobR private key.
If they broadcast,
the counterpart
takes all the funds.
So what are some
optimizations here?
The basic idea of the
script is, OK, you
can have a signature
from KeyA, and you
have to wait a day, or
two, or five, or whatever.
Or you can have a signature from
KeyB and a signature from KeyC.
So what are some
optimizations here?
The revealing part-- any
way to make that smaller,
more efficient?
So one idea is a pre-image
instead of a signature.
You're just revealing
something, you're not actually
committing to any data.
So when Bob reveals his
secret, he could just be,
here's a pre-image.
And instead of like 70
bytes for a signature,
you get down to like 20 bytes
for a hash and a pre-image.
So how would it work?
You'd just say, OK,
Alice signs if Alice
knows BobR's pre-image.
BobR doesn't have to actually
sign, she can just know it.
That would work.
So actually that was
the initial idea.
I think that's what's
written in the paper.
But you can do even smaller.
So an even smaller way
to do it is combine keys.
So in the elliptic
curve that we're
using in all these groups,
all these signature schemes,
if you add two keys together,
you can get a third key.
And it's using the
addition operation
that's defined on this group.
So in the case where
you have KeyB and KeyC,
and you add them together
to get, say, KeyR,
what's the private key for KeyR?
Anyone?
You've got KeyB-- private key--
KeyC, which has a private key,
you add the two public keys
up together--
yeah, it's the sum
of the private keys.
So public KeyB is just private
KeyB times the generator
point, G. But-- and then C
times G equals R times G.
And then you can just move
the parentheses around.
So B plus C, the private
keys added together
times the generator
point is still the same.
So this is a really
nice property.
Actually, it's sort
of the main property
that we use for all
signatures and all this stuff.
What that means is you can say,
here, I take your public key,
I'm going to come up
with my own private key,
compute the public key for that,
add them together, and say,
hey, we've got this
new shared public key.
And neither of us
can sign with it
yet because we don't know
each other's private keys.
But if either of us
reveals the private key,
then the other party
can sign with it.
So if this is Bob's and
this is Alice's, they
can both compute little r times
G by doing this operation.
They both share public keys and
compute the shared public key.
But they cannot sign, because
neither of them knows little r.
And then let's say Alice says,
OK, Bob, here's this little c,
gives it to Bob.
Bob says, OK, now
I know a little r.
But Alice doesn't.
So this is a really
nice way to do it,
because it saves a lot of space.
So instead, the script
is now just KeyD--
oh, I should have put R, oops.
KeyD or KeyA and time.
So instead of having
this key and time passes,
or these other two
keys both sign,
you just have a single key
that can sign immediately,
or another key that can
sign after a period of time.
So the actual
script used is this.
You say OP_IF, the
KeyR, OP_ELSE, delay,
OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY, OP_DROP,
then the KeyA, then the ENDIF,
then the OP_CHECKSIG.
So I'll walk through
this because it's
a little confusing.
The OP_IF takes an
item off the stack,
and it's either true or false.
So the first thing
you have to do
is you have to indicate
which of these two paths
you're going to use.
Either you're going to
put KeyR on the stack,
or you're going to put
this delay number, which
is, say, 100 blocks, put
an OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY
to verify that it has been
100 blocks since you created
the transaction you're spending.
And then you have
to drop the delay.
This was to ensure
compatibility,
since it's a soft fork.
So old nodes would see this.
Old nodes would see this,
they would see a no-op,
and then they would see the drop
to get rid of this whole thing.
So the old nodes
wouldn't see it at all.
Then you have a KeyA
put on the stack,
and then you end
the IF statement,
and then you check signatures.
So really the IF
statement is just
determining which key gets
pushed onto the stack.
And then after the
IF statement, there
is a CHECKSIG to check the
signature from that key.
So for example, if you're
using the revocation
key, the key that has been
combined and revealed to you,
you just put a 1 on the stack,
and then a signature from R.
And then the OP_IF
results to true,
so it executes this by just
pushing the key onto the stack.
Then it executes OP_ELSE,
skips to OP_ENDIF,
and then does OP_CHECKSIG.
So basically you say 1, execute
OP_IF, KeyR, skip to CHECKSIG.
So it's just, you need
to sign with this key.
Or you say 0, and
signature from A.
And then so the OP_IF takes
a 0, it skips to OP_ELSE
because it's not true, it
pushes delay onto the stack,
performs CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY to
make sure that enough time has
passed, drops the delay
number off the stack,
which is a little
ugly-- it would be nicer
if OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY did
that itself, but it doesn't--
then pushes KeyA onto the
stack, ends the IF statement,
and checks the signature.
So it's a little
more complicated
than in C, where you just can
say, KeyD or KeyA and time.
But this is stack-based.
And it's not too hard when
you get these things to work.
So any questions
about this setup?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what's
OP_DROP again?
TADGE DRYJA: OP_DROP takes
the topmost item on the stack
and deletes it, and all the
lower items come back up.
Yeah, it's just so that,
compatibility-wise--
there would be ways to--
since OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY
basically,
this used to be a no-op
where it did nothing.
And then the soft fork was,
OK, we're redefining no-op 3,
I believe, to
OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY, where
it looks at, basically,
the age of your inputs,
and how many confirmations
your inputs have had,
or really the specific input
you're spending in this case.
Old nodes would just
see it as a no-op,
and so you could put
something like delay,
OP_CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY,
and then an OP code
around here that says, make
sure the top item on the stack
is greater than 5.
And if this consumed
the delay value
by taking it off the
stack, the old nodes
might say, oh, this isn't valid.
Even though this is a no-op,
the subsequent OP code
causes this to fail.
Whereas in the new
version, it would be like,
no, this is good because
this consumes that value.
And that would actually make it
a hard fork, because then there
would be transactions
where the old nodes thought
it was not good and the new
nodes thought, yes, this is OK.
So to ensure that
this only restricts
the validity of scripts,
it doesn't pop that off.
So you have to manually drop it.
And DROP is there from before.
So to an old node, it would
say delay, no OP_DROP.
And it's like, OK, you put
something in the stack,
you do nothing, and then you
take it off the stack-- fine.
So that's just a
compatibility thing.
If you were going to
make it from scratch,
you'd probably do
it differently.
Other questions about this?
OK, cool.
So then you reveal keys.
You keep revealing things each
time you make a new state.
And you can do these
several times a second.
You can do it 10 times a
second, something like that.
So you can have
millions, billions
of different old transactions.
The problem is, you
do have to remember
all of these old private keys
that your counterparty has
given to you.
Because if you forget one, they
might broadcast a transaction
where you really need to know
that private key in order
to grab the money immediately.
So for example, you forget--
this was revoked, but you forgot
about it, and you're Alice,
and then Bob broadcasts this.
You really need to
know that private key
so you can grab Bob's five
coins with your combined key.
So you need to keep track of
all of these little things.
So it's 32 bytes each.
It's not great for scalability.
So there's actually a
couple of different ways
you could do this.
How can you remember a
chain of 32-byte secrets?
A merkle tree itself would
have a root here, and then
a bunch of little hashes that
go up to the tree's root.
So if these were secrets--
you can't go back down, right?
So if you're like, OK, I got
secret 0, secret 1, secret 2,
secret 3, well, I've got the
parents of these two things,
but I can't actually
remember them any better.
So a real simple way--
say, OK, I've got--
and you can construct
it however you want.
Obviously if your counterparty
is not cooperating
and these secret numbers
are just completely random,
there's nothing you can do.
If he just says, hey,
I'm going to give you
secret 0, secret 1,
secret 2, there's
no special properties
about these things.
I can't do anything.
The simplest way-- what's
a real simple way to say,
OK, I'm going to reveal
secrets sequentially,
and then you can
store fewer of them?
It's sort of like a
blockchain, right?
[CHUCKLING]
So you could just say, OK,
well, I create secret 3.
Secret 2 is the
hash of secret 3.
Secret 1 is the
hash of secret 2.
And so now I reveal 1.
You don't know what
2 is, and so on.
So 0 equals hash of 1.
So you could just
have a linear chain,
like this, so 0, 1, 2, 3.
If you remember 3, you can
compute 2, and 1, and 0.
If you remember 2, you can
compute 1 and 0, but not 3.
So you can do that.
That would actually
probably work fine.
But we always want to
make unnecessary complex
optimizations to things.
So the problem with this is if
you've got a billion of them,
and you need to go
back to the first one,
you need to compute a
billion hash operations.
That's kind of slow.
So what we do--
or the basic idea,
there's multiple
implementations,
slight variations--
you have a hash tree.
So you reveal secrets
one at a time,
you store only log(n)
secrets, and you
re-compute any secret you want
with something around log(n)
operations.
I called it Elkrem.
I think there's an
actual paper that
basically is this, called GGM.
And that's, I think,
written by people at MIT.
But I called it Elkrem because
it's basically a merkle
tree backwards, because
the arrows point
the other direction.
So in this case, you
start with a route-- you
start with something up here.
And you say, OK, if I
wanted to send to the left,
I append a 0 to the
hash value of this root,
and I hash to get that one.
And if I want to go right,
I append a 1 at the end,
hash that, and then
I go down here.
So what that lets you do is--
there is a sender
and a receiver.
The sender just computes
a route, and stores that.
They make a random
route up, store it,
and then they also
keep track of,
OK how many secrets
have I given?
The receiver just receives
the first one, number 0--
can't do anything.
They receive 1.
OK, still can't do anything.
They receive 2.
Now they can say, OK, well
I can throw away 0 and 1,
because if I want to compute
0 and 1, I can just store 2.
And if I want them
to send to the left,
append to zero, and hash if
I want to send to the right--
So I don't store
these, but I know
they're still computable
for me if I ever
want to grab them back.
I receive 3, can't do anything.
I receive 4, can't do anything.
I receive 5, now I can do
the same thing with 3 and 4,
remove those from the disk,
and only store 2 and 5.
So if I get a request for
3, I can easily compute it.
And then I receive 6, and I
can delete those two as well.
So as I go up the
tree, sometimes I only
have to store one
thing, sometimes
I have to store three
things, because that's
the height of the tree.
Well, it's basically you
have to store at most one
on every level, and
then sometimes two
if there are two leaves.
So basically log(n) storage,
and computing hashes
is pretty quick, too.
So that's a fun way
to only have to store
a very small amount of data.
Any questions about this?
OK, so we're going quick.
[INAUDIBLE] quick.
OK, so we'll talk about
cross-chain swaps for most
of the bulk of this day.
So there are altcoins.
I mostly work on Bitcoin.
I think a lot of the
research is on Bitcoin.
But there's a lot of
different coins, too.
People saw the idea of Bitcoin
and said, hey, let's copy it.
So initially, most of
them were just copies.
There was a site
called coingen.io.
So like 2012,
there started to be
a lot of all coins, like
Litecoin, and Dogecoin,
and things like that.
And most of them were
real small changes,
where they took the Bitcoin
source code on GitHub,
and they changed a couple
numbers here and there,
and they said, OK,
well, it's a new coin.
And then BlueMatt made a site
called coingen.io, where you
could do it all very easily.
For people who weren't
programming-savvy,
they could just make their
own altcoin by menus.
There's a website, you say, I
want it to be called Tadgecoin,
I want there to be 25
coins every three minutes,
and I want--
you know, just a
bunch of things.
You could upload
a little picture,
and it would make a program
for you based on those things.
And then I think
he sold the site.
I think it was the first
blockchain technology company,
as far as I'm concerned.
OK, so then recent ones
are very different.
People trade altcoins
for bitcoins,
and trade altcoins for altcoins,
and they use exchanges.
I don't know if--
have people here used
exchanges to trade altcoins?
Some.
I actually have.
I hadn't until last year.
But there was these
sort of hard forks
from Bitcoin, like Bitcoin
Cash, and Bitcoin Gold,
and Bitcoin whatever.
And so I actually
opened an account,
and sold them, and
got more Bitcoins.
[CHUCKLING]
How do you trade?
Well, you use an exchange.
And so the current
exchange model,
pretty much without fail,
is give us all your coins,
post orders on our site
to swap with other users,
and then ask for
your coins back.
So the "give us all your
coins" part, it works fine.
They give you an address,
you send your coins
to their address, and
it'll appear on their site,
generally.
But you definitely
can send your coins.
The "ask for your coins back" is
where the model tends to fail.
There's many, many cases where
they don't give them back.
And there's a lot
of reasons for this.
So Mt.
Gox was one of the most
prominent early ones,
but it certainly
wasn't the first.
Probably one of the first
was called MyBitcoins.com.
And then it was sort of--
I don't know if it
was intentional,
but the joke, after, was like,
well, it's his bitcoins now.
[CHUCKLING]
It was more of a web wallet
that had private keys
than an actual exchange.
But a lot of these exchanges--
they're really easy to set up.
You just write some
software, and people
start sending you coins.
And then either there's
internal problems
where you've got
some rogue employee,
or the rogue employee
is the only employee,
and someone just realizes, hey,
this computer in front of me
has $20 million
worth of stuff on it.
I think I'll just unplug
it and keep all the money.
Also hackers, right?
They're probably
the best targets
for trying to intrude
and hack into a system
that you can find.
Because there's a whole ton
of money on this computer.
It's not like data or, oh, I
get someone's Facebook pictures
or I get someone's
credit card numbers.
Yeah, that's nice, but
bitcoins are sort of money,
and you just steal them.
OK, so other problems
with the exchange model
is that people tend
to trust it a lot,
and they think, well, this is--
they assume that
it's like a bank,
and banks are very trustworthy,
because in recent memory
there haven't really been
bank failures, at least
in this country.
So they sort of carry that trust
forward, and bad things happen.
So the idea is,
wouldn't it be cool
if we could have
cross-chain swaps, where
we have some kind of way where,
I've got a bunch of coinA,
you've got a bunch of
coinB, and we can swap
between them without giving
custody to some third party
or even giving
custody to each other.
So you can do this using Hash
Time Locked Contracts, just
like in the Lighting Network.
So you get this coin if and
only if I get this other coin.
You want them to be atomic.
Even if it's very quick, you
don't want any period of time
in which one party has all the
assets or more of the assets.
So the interesting
thing about this
is the Lightning Network
sort of does this already.
The Lightning Network is a
way to make atomic payments
between different channels.
And then if you look at
these channels and say,
well, do the channels have
to be on the same coin,
do they have to be in
the same blockchain?
And basically, no,
not much difference
has to happen for them to
be different blockchains.
OK, so this is the HTLC
slide from last time.
It's similar in that you have
these two outputs, the same as
in a regular lightning payment
channel that's at rest.
So for example, Bob holds this,
where if he broadcasts this,
Alice gets two coins
right off the bat,
Bob needs to wait 100 blocks, or
Alice can know Bob's revocation
key, and she can get seven coins
or he gets the seven coins.
And then you've got this HTLC,
Hash Time Locked Contract,
where Alice needs to a
pre-image [INAUDIBLE]..
Well, yeah, Alice needs to
know R, this receipt, or Bob
has to wait.
But the difference in waiting
is this is a relative time lock,
so that Bob has to wait 100
blocks after he broadcasts
this transaction.
Whereas in this case, Bob has
to wait until height 500,000,
regardless of when he
broadcasts this transaction.
So it may be that he can
broadcast this transaction
and immediately spend
by signing here,
because that time has passed.
So it's seems like
a small distinction,
but it's actually pretty
important for this
to be just absolute time.
So that's how an HTLC works.
This output's
Alice's, no question.
This output should be Bob's.
And by should, I
mean something's
gone pretty seriously wrong
if Alice takes this money.
This only is due to fraud.
And fraud is not like in
a legal, defined sense.
But we sort of can
think of, basically,
this is always going to be
Alice's, this is approximately
always going to be Bob's.
This one, we're really not sure.
This can fail, and it's
not due to any malice.
This can-- it should be Alice's.
You're trying to pay Alice here.
But it may well be the case
that Bob takes it back.
And that's not due
to fraud, that's
just due to computers crashing,
or networks not working right,
or something like that.
This can sort of
innocently be broadcast
and go back to Bob,
whereas this can't, really.
Any questions about
the HTLC basic idea?
So Alice needs to
know this secret,
or Bob has to wait
until a certain time.
OK, so the cross-chain
swaps is basically
the same as a routing
payment in Lightning.
Before, we said, OK, Alice
has a channel with Bob,
Bob has a channel
with Carol, and now
Alice wants to pay Carol
without opening a new channel.
In the case of
lightning, where it's
all on the same
blockchain, Alice
could open a payment
channel to Carol
and spend directly that way.
In the case where these two
are different blockchains,
you can't actually do that.
You can't say,
oh, I'm going to--
there's no defined
channel that will
link two different blockchains.
The other aspect
is, although this
can work with three
parties, in the case
of swaps, you're
generally not saying,
hey, Bob, I will pay you five
Dogecoins if you pay Carol 100
Vertcoins.
You're usually saying, if
you pay me 100 Vertcoins.
So usually it's
Alice sending to Bob,
who's sending back to Alice.
It still works if this is
the third party, Carol.
But it sort of doesn't make as
much sense, because generally
you're saying, hey, I'll give
you this if you give me that.
So in this case, we have
two different blockchains.
We've actually reduced
the number of parties,
where it's just Alice and Bob.
But we've got two
different blockchains.
We've got Dogecoin,
which I think is yellow,
and then Vertcoin is greenish.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Oh, because
they don't have SegWit.
Well, say Dogecoin
upgrades pretty soon.
[CHUCKLING]
So you could, but you'd
have to write a lot of code
to deal with that.
And to us, it's way
easier to just merge and--
AUDIENCE: They don't have
CHECKSEQUENCEVERIFY on?
There's probably ways
around it, but yeah--
TADGE DRYJA: Just upgrade--
who's in charge of Doge?
I don't know.
Tell them to upgrade.
So a lot of these
altcoins, there's
sort of archaeological
aspects to them,
where you can see
where they branched off
of the main Bitcoin codebase.
Because a lot of times
they don't get updated
because no one's
really working on them.
Despite no one really working
on them or looking at them,
they can still be worth
a billion dollars,
as I think Doge was
a few months ago.
So sometimes they catch
up, and they're like,
oh, let's take all the code
from Bitcoin that they've
developed from the last
few years and apply it.
Sometimes the opposite
happens, where an altcoin will
make something cool, and people
in Bitcoin will merge it in,
but it's generally the
opposite direction.
OK, so you've got these two
channels that have been set up.
And Alice wants to sell her
Dogecoin and buy Vertcoin.
So you have the same HTLC
construction, where Alice--
what's interesting in
this case is that it's
the same person on both sides.
So there's actually some
optimizations you can use.
But forget those for a second.
Alice computes a
random number, R,
hashes it to make
H. She sends it
to herself, which doesn't really
make any sense in this case.
So you can skip that step.
Alice already knows H
and already knows R, so--
but Alice doesn't have to
be Alice, it could be Carol.
So there's optimizations
that you can do
when they're the same person.
OK, so she constructs
an HTLC to Bob.
She says, OK, if Bob knows
R, he gets this money.
Otherwise, Alice gets
it after 5 o'clock.
Bob says, OK, I don't know R,
so I can't get these Dogecoins.
Bob then forwards it to Alice,
saying, OK, if Alice knows R,
she gets the coins, if Bob
waits till after 4 o'clock,
he gets the coins.
So it's sort of like why
make this construction?
It actually still makes sense,
because even though Bob knows
that Alice knows R, Alice
will have to reveal R in order
to take the coins, right?
So it's saying, OK,
you need to know R,
and you need to not just know R,
but you have to show everyone.
Because the actual
script says, OK, you
need to know the pre-image
of this 20-byte hash.
And when you actually
spend, you have
to put that pre-image
in the blockchain.
You have to put it in your
input for your transaction,
and then Bob can see it.
So the idea is, if Alice closes
this channel in Vertcoin,
takes the coins by using
R, Bob will know R,
and Bob will know it's
the same R that he
can use to take the coins
on the Dogecoin network.
So you add these two HTLCs.
You then clear them out.
So instead of revealing
R on the blockchain,
Alice can just reveal
R directly to Bob,
say, I'm clearing out
this HTLC because here's
R. You know that I can do this,
so just give me the coins.
You also know R, so you
can take the coins yourself
if I don't cooperate
on that end.
But hopefully she does.
So then you can get
rid of the HTLC.
Now it's back down
the two outputs.
And then Bob says, OK,
I've lost the Vertcoin
and I haven't really
gotten the Dogecoin yet,
but I know I can close the
channel and take it if need be.
And then Bob goes
to Alice, and she
already knows R, but look, you
know that I know R, let's clear
this.
And then Alice can just
send the coins that way.
OK, so any questions
about this setup?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Because
there's latency,
can Alice mess with Bob,
basically, take the Vertcoin
before Bob has a
chance to get the Doge,
and basically screw Bob?
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, well, that's
why you have different times
here.
So yes, that is possible, that
you could get to this step,
and then Alice goes offline
and shuts the channels down,
closes the channels.
But the idea is that Bob
can grab these coins back
after 4 PM, whereas Alice
has to wait until 5 PM
to grab these coins back.
So if Alice closes and tries to
wait till right before 4:00 PM
and then immediately grab
these coins, Bob's actually OK.
Because Bob says, OK, well,
you grabbed the Vertcoins,
but I actually have another
hour until I have to--
I have an hour to reveal
R where you're not
able to get these coins back.
So having this incrementing
time can help against that.
An hour is probably not enough.
The trade-off to
having these times
is, if you have it
very far in the future,
with very large gaps, those
HTLCs can get stuck there.
And if Alice just
says, look, I'm
leaving this third output
in the transaction,
that can be annoying.
Or if it gets stuck on chain,
it might take a long time
to get it back.
So you want long
enough times that you
don't worry about
these timing attacks,
where someone
immediately broadcasts,
and now you only have an
hour, and maybe the blockchain
is congested.
Versus the annoyance
of, oh, it closed,
and now I have to
wait until 5:00 PM.
So those are the
trade-offs there.
Any other questions?
OK, so cross-chain swaps--
H can be revealed-- sorry, R--
well, H just goes
into either chain,
R is then revealed
on either chain,
so that both parties need
to watch both blockchains.
This sort of makes sense,
in that the channels are
on two different
blockchains, and both parties
have a channel on each.
So the receiver doesn't
need to be the initiator.
So it doesn't have to
be Alice on both sides,
but in most cases I think
it probably will be.
Alice has a Vertcoin
channel, Alice also
has a Dogecoin
channel, as does Bob.
So they need to be
operating on both networks.
There are possibilities where
if you had, say, this was Carol,
and she sent to Dave
using Litecoin--
so if you have Alice, Bob,
Carol, Dave, Doge, Vertcoin,
Litecoin--
Alice would not have to know
about anything but Dogecoin.
So you actually only have
to worry about the networks
that you have channels in,
even though there are secrets
that could appear in other--
well, no, sorry,
that's not true.
So if this is Carol, Alice
does have to look at Vertcoin,
because the Vertcoin
network could show things.
So you have to look at
one additional chain.
So that's one of the issues
with cross-chain swaps, where
you may be routing
through a network
that you're not aware
of, essentially.
I don't think that's
likely in practice.
So like it could
be, I'll send you
five Dogecoins if you
send her 20 Litecoins,
and then you send back
Dogecoins to this other place,
but it's possible.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to make sure
that I'm understanding this.
So when they're both Alice,
essentially that scenario
is Alice is exchanging
Dogecoin for Vertcoin.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then
if on the right
is Carol, that's saying Alice is
going to pay Carol in Dogecoin,
even though she's
receiving Vertcoin.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
Carol receives Vertcoin,
Alice loses Dogecoin.
So it's an exchange [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So it's like you're
paying [INAUDIBLE] never see
[INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah.
So like you go to
some other country--
you go to England, you
pay with your credit card,
you lose dollars
but they get pounds.
And there's somehow-- there's
an exchange rate in the middle.
And so from Bob's perspective,
it works the same either way.
He's getting more Dogecoins
and losing Vertcoins.
AUDIENCE: So Bob needs
to have a lot of--
well, in this case, he only
really needs Vertcoins.
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
So it's possible that you set
up this by initially funding it.
So Alice says, I have
a ton of Dogecoin.
Alice creates this channel,
and she has like 100 dogecoins,
and Bob has zero.
And same with Vertcoin--
Bob could have a lot
of them, and say, OK,
I have 20 vertcoins
and Alice has zero,
and then we can make those
payments in that direction.
You can pay them--
so actually, in all the
software now, I think,
there's only
single-funded channels.
Because having both parties
funded at the same time
is kind of--
software-wise, a little harder,
and it's also, interface-wise,
going to be complicated.
Because how do you know when
to match someone's funding?
So usually what
you do is you say,
I'm Alice, hey Bob,
what's your public key?
Give me a new public key.
OK, I'm going to
construct this channel.
Here, sign this.
And then Bob's like, OK.
And Bob has no money at stake
when this process happens.
And then Bob also creates a
channel with Alice, saying,
OK, I'm going to put a bunch
of Vertcoin in this channel.
And they usually start with
all the money on one side
so they can then trade.
Other questions?
So they have to look at
these different channels
on different blockchains in
order to make sure this works.
There's still a lot of
open questions here.
How do you actually trade?
This is really good
for trade execution,
but what about discovery?
So the current exchanges,
they're not just
"put all your money in here
and then ask for it back,"
there's that middle step where
you find all the other parties.
So post the orders on the
blockchain, and maybe?
There's problems-- I mean,
it's not too crazy of an idea,
but there's some
problems with it.
If you just say, hey, I
want to sell dogecoins
and I want to buy
vertcoins, and you sort of
put that in an OP_RETURN
on the blockchain, well,
it's non-binding.
You don't have to
actually do anything.
There can be frontrunning,
where the orders
can go in the wrong
sequence or in time.
And it's not scalable, because
if everyone's posting orders
on the blockchain, that
can take up a lot of space,
probably more so than
actual transactions.
I don't know what--
I mean, I'm sure-- maybe.
Total number of orders
placed on a order
book versus total number
of actual order executions,
usually there's a
lot more orders that
then end up getting canceled.
Because in most exchanges
that I've seen--
and I believe this is the
case in regular New York Stock
Exchange kind of
things, you can say,
hey, I want to sell
this at this price,
and then a few minutes later you
say, yeah, I changed my mind.
I don't to sell it at
that price anymore.
The price has moved, and
I've changed my mind.
And a lot of times--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: The New
York Stock Exchange
runs about 100 messages
for every executed trade.
TADGE DRYJA: OK, so about 1% of
the actual trades get executed.
Yeah, that sounds
probably about the same
as in a lot of
Bitcoin exchanges.
Usually in the
Bitcoin exchanges,
they don't charge you to post
an order and then take it back.
That's free.
Whereas the trade
actually executing,
usually they have
some kind of fee.
So posting the orders
themselves on the blockchain
seems like a cool
idea, but you've
got, now, this
scalability problem
of all these transactions.
Now it's probably
100 times worse.
And frontrunning
could also be tricky.
Because the blockchain does
provide sequence and timing,
but it's up to the miners.
So if you have a
10-minute window,
during that 10-minute
window, the miners
can basically shuffle things
around however they want.
And so if the miner
is also trading,
they can see, oh, I see
all these different orders,
I will match these orders, and
let those happen afterwards.
So this is an issue.
So there's a bunch of different
models people are looking at.
And to be clear here, this is
not something that really--
I don't want to say it doesn't
exist yet, it sort of does.
There are these decentralized
exchanges popping up, mostly
on the Ethereum
network right now.
Because then it's not
actually cross-chain.
You can have cross-asset,
because there's
all these ERC-20 tokens.
But the cross-chain swaps
themselves are a bit more
complicated to program.
So I don't know of any
live, not-Mainnet operation
like this.
So one model would be you
have a central order book
and a central counterparty.
So the exchange says, OK,
we're still the exchange,
we still have a website,
we still have order--
buys, and sells,
and stuff like that.
And not only that,
but the exchange
is one side of every trade.
So they say, OK, open
a channel with us,
put all your vertcoins in,
put all your dogecoins in.
And then we'll open a
different channel with you,
and we'll put litecoins in it.
And you trade with us.
But then what they can
do is they can say,
well, we're not
actually going to trade
unless there's someone
else performing
a similar, opposite trade.
And then they can
keep the spread.
So they say, OK, we're
selling Vertcoin at this rate
and buying it at this other,
slightly different rate.
So that seems the most feasible.
I would venture that that's
going to happen first,
because it's not too crazy.
But it has similar
centralization
to the current model.
But there is less
counterparty risk.
So if you are worried
about an exchange shutting
down and running off with all
your Dogecoin, this can help.
Say, OK, well, I have a
channel with my Dogecoin in it
and a channel with
my Vertcoin in it,
and I can sell some
Dogecoin, get some Vertcoin
from the exchange, and I
still have a nice order book.
It doesn't solve any kind
of frontrunning problem.
The exchange can still
order things how they want.
And the exchange
can still shut down.
But it's much more
difficult for the exchange
to somehow steal your coins,
which is a problem now.
Another model-- you say, well,
we have a central order book,
so the exchange still
exists and aggregates
all the orders of everyone
who wants to buy and sell.
But there's multiple
counterparties
that you interact with directly.
So the exchange says,
OK, I'm E, and I
will tell Alice about Bob.
Alice says, hey, I
want to sell Dogecoin
and buy Vertcoin at this rate.
And then the exchange tells
Alice and Bob, OK, you guys
matched.
Bob, you want to sell Vertcoin,
Alice, you want to buy it.
Here, connect to each other
and perform this trade.
This is cooler, but
there's questions,
in that if you're connecting
to many counterparties,
it's costly.
You have to open a new
channel, and that is on chain.
Also, how do you
enforce trade execution?
If it's a trade on a current
exchange, and you say,
OK, I want to buy bitcoins,
And you click, OK, it just
happened.
They are aren't
even your bitcoins.
You don't really
have control of them.
So when you say you
want to do something,
they actually execute it.
In this case, if they don't
have a channel with you,
they just are observing
the trade occur.
So they're saying, OK,
Alice and Bob, do this.
It might not even be
possible to enforce.
You'd have to have
some kind of penalties
if Bob says hey, Alice,
said she was going to sell,
but then didn't, or Bob
complains, things like that.
So there's a lot of ideas here.
Another is, OK, if
you're building channels,
each channel that you built
has these unchained costs
and takes quite a bit of time.
So maybe you could have
a multi-hop network
from different coins.
So instead of just
Alice, Bob, Alice,
you've got Dave and Carol.
And as long as I'm connected
to someone in this network,
I can route payments to them
and they can route payments
to me via different channels.
So I'm connected to this
multicoin network kind of mesh.
That would be really cool.
It's not implemented.
It's not even really
researched that well yet.
So these are sort of ideas.
But that would be really cool.
Then you wouldn't need
as much liquidity.
So one of the issues with the
central counterparty model
is the exchange still needs
to have a bunch of money.
They still need to have a bunch
of dogecoins and vertcoins
in order to be a
counterparty to every trade.
And then the question is, well,
where did those come from?
And if you say, oh, well, it
comes from customers, well,
now that's back into
the custodial model,
where they still have coins
that aren't really theirs.
You could say, well, they--
and what I'm guessing
is going to happen
is they're going to say,
well, we charge a spread,
and we'll accept investors.
And so if you want to
invest in this exchange,
give us a bunch of Dogecoin,
give us a bunch of Vertcoin.
We will then use it to trade
with different parties,
and then we'll keep
some kind of spread,
and then, hey, you got a return
on your invested Dogecoin.
You get more
Dogecoin at the end,
and then you can withdraw it.
I think this is still better
than the current model, where
you leave a whole bunch
of coins on the exchange,
and you get nothing.
Now you can choose--
OK, do I want to
give them my coins
and take that counterparty
risk, but I get some return
in exchange for that
risk, or do I just
want to trade without
counterparty risk.
So, another problem
with that model.
But that's probably
what will happen.
This doesn't have that
issue, in that there
is no central counterparty who
needs to have a bunch of coins.
I'm trading directly with
the people who own the coins
and want to sell.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My question
is, even if you
have this central role and
multiple counterparties,
wouldn't there still
be these trader nodes
that are going to go out
there and essentially
be kind of the same thing?
They're going to be
well-funded, they're
going take fees by doing all
these different transactions,
and they're going to
get bigger and bigger.
TADGE DRYJA: Yes, I guess
the only distinction is--
so yes,
AUDIENCE: It just
allows it to happen--
TADGE DRYJA: Over the not
even long term-- medium term--
these, as a user interface,
they'll look the same.
Because whether
it's the exchange
itself saying, OK,
I'm aggregating,
everyone deposit, I've
got a ton of capital,
I'm going to be a counterparty
to these trades and a market
maker, versus, oh, there's
no defined market maker,
but the people
with a lot of money
or who are really trying to do
this end up in that position.
I guess the only difference
is, in this case,
the counterparty is also
running the order book.
And in this case,
they may be different.
There's an order book
server, and then there's
this big counterparty who
has a ton of money who's
doing all the trades.
So does that make
much of a difference.
I don't know.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: In the
history of markets,
the second example is the
one that you see more.
AUDIENCE: Right, yeah, right?
New York Stock Exchange, London
Stock Exchange, and so on.
The first model has
the centralized party
collecting huge economic rents
because they're centralized,
which is kind of interesting,
where Bitcoin was
supposed to be decentralized.
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah,
so this probably
ends up with a small
number of pretty big nodes,
mostly because of
the efficiency.
If you're connecting to 100
different counterparties,
and then you never actually
trade with any of them,
it's very costly to
build those channels,
and which probably has
analogies to, in real life,
it's costly to maintain
these relationships
with all these different
companies and stuff.
It's much more efficient
if we just all meet
under this buttonwood tree.
It's a different issue in that,
enforcing trade execution,
you might not have legal--
you might not know who any
of these people are legally.
So you have some
kind of penalties
or some kind of proofs that the
trade occurred the correct way,
things like that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How about
the enforcing--
[INAUDIBLE] what we'd call
it, but the way the trades are
set up, do you need
to enforce them,
or before you enter into
them, do you already
know what [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: So the
example is, before you--
OK, so the example is,
Alice goes to a server.
So you have an exchange,
but this exchange
is only the order book.
So there's little buy
and sell kind of things.
And then Alice says,
OK, I want to buy VTC.
And then-- this is Alice--
Bob says, OK, I want
to buy Dogecoin.
Then the exchange says,
oh, you guys crossed.
You want to buy
Vertcoin at a rate
that he's willing to sell at,
or slightly higher, or whatever,
so trade.
So the exchange tells both
people, hey, you matched,
now you have to trade.
And then as soon as A sees, oh,
you matched, you have to trade,
Alice disappears, and
says, oh, I didn't mean to.
So the exchange only
can provide information.
They can't actually
force Alice and Bob
to do the trade is the problem.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I guess you can broadcast--
in broadcasting your
potential trade,
there's information for somebody
to come in at those-- so
if it's at a specific
price, and you're actually
publishing what you would need
to actually execute the trade.
TADGE DRYJA: Ah, so that--
yeah, at least in Bitcoin,
I don't know how to do that.
Because you need to know who
your counterparty is in order
to either use these channels,
or even if it were on chain,
you have to share these secret--
it's interactive with
your counterparty.
So at least in Bitcoin, I
don't know a way to say,
Alice is posting her buy
Vertcoin order in a way
that anyone can
then go and fill it
without additional
interactivity from Alice.
I think there's ways
to do that in Ethereum,
for Ethereum tokens, and
there are people who've
written software like that.
But in the Bitcoin model,
there might be a way to do it.
We haven't figured it out.
So it's sort of--
you put in your orders,
they return and say, OK,
trade, and now--
AUDIENCE: You have to
create the [INAUDIBLE]..
TADGE DRYJA: Yeah, now they
have to continue to interact.
So it's pretty straightforward
for Bob or Alice--
Alice could just unplug her
computer right at that point.
And that introduces timing
sort of issues where Alice just
puts in all these fake trades.
Maybe they're kind of out there.
But sometimes the market
moves during the time
between I put my trade in
and the execution comes back.
And so I unplug most of them.
I ignore most of them, but
the ones that are beneficial,
I actually go through with.
AUDIENCE: Which isn't too far
from the way the markets work.
TADGE DRYJA: Well, yeah.
[CHUCKLING]
AUDIENCE: The
difference is, you're
saying these are not live
hot bids and hot offers,
meaning executable.
They had another step
if they were executable.
So this is a new
form of spoofing.
This spoofing goes on
in the US swaps market
all the time, because
[INAUDIBLE] bids and offers.
But in the market where
there's executable bids
and offers, that's the
distinction-- this is not hot.
[INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: Right.
I guess so "hot" in
this case would be--
if Alice's offer contains all
the information needed by Bob
to execute the
trade, then it would
be sort of hot in that
sense, in that Bob
doesn't have to interact with
Alice anymore to execute.
With these construction--
with the cross-chain swaps,
using these channels, you still
have to talk to each other.
Bob generates-- no, Alice
generates the R value,
shares the hash with Bob.
They're talking to each other.
So we don't know--
if someone figures out a cool
way to do it, then great,
that will solve this issue.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is 0x and Radar
Relay, are they hot [INAUDIBLE]
TADGE DRYJA: I believe 0x
is, from what I've read.
I don't know about how
[STAMMERING] whatever that is--
Radar Relay works.
But 0x, yeah,
basically, your order
is executable by any party
without further input from you.
But it also has scaling issues.
So that's a good segue way
to the next part, which
is having some kind of
distributed order book, where
there is no central
order book, there
is no central counterparty,
the whole thing
is a big mesh network
kind of thing.
That would be really cool.
That seems the furthest out, in
terms of, how do you do this.
I mean, people
are working on it,
but it seems hard to
make practical in that
how do you ensure
fairness, right?
Who's ordering these things?
And you could say,
well, the blockchain
is ordering these things.
But that ends up being
that the miners order it.
So if Alice is buy
Vertcoin, she's like, OK,
I'm buying Vertcoin
at a price of 5.
And then he says,
OK, I'll buy Doge
at a price of whatever--
basically, you cross,
and you have an order where
there's some kind of overlap.
The miner can say, OK, well,
I'll instead ignore this order,
execute my own, and then
execute with this guy
and take the spread.
Because the miner really gets
to sequence things however
they want.
The blockchain does
provide ordering,
but at the block level.
Within a block, it's
totally up to the miner.
So the miners could
swap things around.
But yeah, how do you ensure
fairness in terms of timing?
How do you enforce
trade execution?
And probably the biggest
for a distributed order book
is just the scalability
of the orders.
You probably don't want to put
all the orders on a blockchain,
because it just ends
up being a ton of data.
So you have to have some
kind of broadcast network
where you've got these
orders, they probably
should have some way to
expire, but expiry is also
an issue in that, how
do you ensure that--
hey, I'm canceling
this order, how
do you ensure that the
cancellation actually
propagates if someone
can say, OK, I've
got pretty good
control of the network,
and I can just block
these order cancellations,
and wait, and then execute.
So this is sort of--
there's papers, there's ideas,
but it's kind of out there.
OK, so that's basically--
yeah, that was it.
That's a little earlier.
But yeah, this was basically
the stuff for today.
The idea works, right,
the cross-chain swaps.
But there's still a lot
of issues, in terms of,
OK, how do you actually
get these to work?
How do you build a
scalable trading platform?
And there aren't really any yet.
There are some things on
Ethereum that work OK.
The fees end up
being kind of high.
And that's also
Ethereum, where it's not
between different blockchains.
It's all running on
the Ethereum network,
and the Ethereum network
allows you to specify,
well, this is actually something
else, this isn't ether.
You can do that
in Bitcoin, but--
so there are
protocols in Bitcoin,
like Omni, and
Mastercoin, and things,
where you can sort of
create different assets
by using OP_RETURN.
And basically all of those
have moved to Ethereum now,
because Ethereum is a much
nicer design for those things.
And most of the Bitcoin
developers are sort of like,
great, now all these non-Bitcoin
transaction data have left,
and Bitcoin is just focused
on moving bitcoin around.
Yeah, so the basic
idea works, there's
still a lot of unsolved
questions-- further research
required, which is great to
hear when you're a researcher.
[CHUCKLING]
And there's people
working on this here.
I'm working with an MEng
student on cross-chain swaps
this semester.
There's other people
working on all sorts
of decentralized
exchange things.
Neha is also very
interested in it.
So if you want to work
with Neha, that's a chance.
And yeah, I think
it'll be big, right?
Because if you look
at these exchanges,
there's a lot of profit.
So I don't know, a year or two
ago, you look at like Poloniex,
they were making like
$1 million a day.
There's so much volume.
And they have very
few employees.
So and they're like--
I think the market is getting
sort of more established now,
in terms of its going
to be larger players
and stuff like that.
But it was pretty much like
Wild Wild West a few years ago,
where you're just like, I'm
going to open an exchange,
and I don't even
need a bank account.
The big exchanges that have
bank accounts I feel like
are less profitable.
So Coinbase makes
a lot of revenue,
but they have a lot of fees--
a lot of costs.
They have a ton of employees,
they have a ton of lawyers,
they have to worry about banks.
Whereas if you're
like Poloniex-- well,
Poloniex is now--
it lasted for like a year or
two where they could do that.
But if you're just some
random altcoin exchange,
you don't need a bank account.
You just say, look,
I'm an exchange where
you can trade Dogecoin and
Vertcoin, and that's it.
There's no dollars involved.
So those kind of
places, they can open up
on any server,
anywhere in the world.
They don't even need
to be companies,
they can just be
someone's server.
And the fact that
they have custody
means they keep
getting shut down
or just running off with money.
Crypsy-- Crypsy was
that guy, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
exchange wallet
as like his own
personal bank account.
Yeah, spent all
the money one day.
TADGE DRYJA: Right, so--
and then he said--
I remember there was a blog
post where he just sort of said
he did that.
And it was just like--
AUDIENCE: He was
trying to justify it.
Like yeah, we're making fees
and stuff, so it was OK,
we though we could
[INAUDIBLE] It's
like where the two graphs
just diverge, unfortunately,
and it went to zero.
TADGE DRYJA: But it was
just an amazing blog post,
where it's like,
wait, you're just
admitting to a whole
bunch of crimes here,
you probably shouldn't
have written this.
And then he fled to China,
but I think they got him.
He's in jail now or something.
So there's a lot of you
know pretty bad actors
in the exchange space.
It's not well-run generally.
But there's enormous amounts
of profit, which, to me, seems
like an inefficiency, right?
Wait, why are these people
making $1 million a day
for something that is sort
of just running automatically
on this computer?
That seems like
ripe for disruption.
And so there's a lot of
people interested in, OK,
how do we decentralize
the exchanges,
make them less trust-involved,
less risk-involved,
and probably make less money
than Paloniex, or OK coin,
or whatever.
But that's sort of better,
because an exchange where
there's less profitability
means more people are
going to want to trade on it
because there's lower fees.
So there's a lot of
research into this.
I think it's pretty cool.
So next class, on
Wednesday, I'll
talk about discrete
log contracts, which
share some of these issues,
in that it's a different way
to execute a trade,
but it doesn't really
define how you find people
to execute that trade.
I personally am more interested
in the discrete log contract
stuff, probably because
I came up with it,
but also because I'm not
that excited about altcoins
in general.
I don't know, people
like altcoins,
but I don't really
feel that, oh, we
need to have all these different
altcoins that sort of act
like money--
I don't know--
which is mostly what
cross-chain swaps let you do.
So the discrete log
contracts, though,
has the same issues with
how do you find each other.
And it's mostly a
scalability thing, right?
You can do this sort of OTC,
where you talk in a chat room,
and you sort of know each
other, and you trade that way.
And that's the level
it is right now.
But how to scale it up
is another question.